hey everyone this is kevin from
thechesswebsite.com and today we're
going to be going over my favorite way
to attack the grunfeld defense and
that's with the nadanian attack and if
you haven't seen it before
you may scratch your head a bit because
it takes some of the basic opening
principles
and throws them out the window but it's
still a very sound opening and i'll show
you in this video
why that is the case so if you're not
familiar with the greenfield starts out
with
d4 knight to f6 c4 white controlling the
center with the pawns here
we have g6 knight to c3 and then
d5 so black looking to push forward here
with d5
while controlling it with this knight on
f6 as well as the queen on
d8 eventually bring the bishop to g7
castle on the king side more of that
hyper modern defense where you are
controlling the center of the board with
your minor pieces and then later you
start to push forward
with your pawns and you can push on the
queen's head of the board if you want to
later you can start to push forward with
your e-pawn as well
uh white's gonna take here on d5 and
after the
knight takes you know you could have
your main line in the grunfell would
just
be uh pawnee ford knight takes pawn
recaptures but that's not
what we're going to be playing today and
not my preferred line i usually like to
play openings that are both
uh sound although sometimes i do like to
play unsound openings that i can catch
my opponent off guard
and in the nadanian attack we're looking
to play the move knight to a4
completely throwing out two very key
components in opening principles and
that one
is don't move a piece twice if you don't
have to you want to get multiple pieces
involved into the game you don't
just want to move one piece all around
the board you can see we've moved to
knight to c3 and then we've moved it to
a4 and the second one is you definitely
don't want to bring your knight to the
edge
of the board the a file or the h file
you want it in the center of the board
controlling as many squares as possible
but this knight on a4 does something
critical
and that is to control the square here
on c5
as we mentioned earlier when we're
talking about where the squares
for white would be in the main line we
would have one on
c3 d4 and e4
but things get kind of tricky when all
of a sudden black can push forward at
some point with
c5 it blows up the center of the board
here
and so this knight on a4 says what if we
just start attacking the square right
away
and how does black really counter this
so this is what we're going to be
talking about that
today there's a few variations that i do
want to cover
the first one is the mainline bishop to
g7 immediately playing the square
or the the piece that black intends to
playing in the grunfeld and that is
bishop to g7 preparing to castle on the
king side
uh the other one we're going to be
looking at is knight to c6 immediately
attacking the square here on
d4 which black can still play g7 at some
point
we're also going to be looking at e5 if
they just want to attack the pawn
right away with their own pawn or b5 if
they want to attack
our knight here on a4
i will have a link in the description
below if you want to
ever click ahead or if you ever come
back to this video and you want to see
any of those specific variations
those are the four that we will be
covering in this video
the first one is bishop here to g7
immediately it's hacking the pawn here
on
d4 the main theme
with this opening for white is to
continue with the main
plan that you would normally attack the
grunfeld and that is to play pawn to e4
the difference is that black can't play
knight takes on
c3 which they normally play and so they
have to come up with other alternatives
they could play knight to f6 you don't
see this as often because
people don't like to bring their knight
back to the same square that it was
you could always push forward with
knight to e5
if you wanted to you just don't see it
all that often so
you could see knight to b6 attacking the
knight here on
a4 now bishop to
e3 we do have the dark square bishop and
the queen both eyeing down at the square
here on
d4 so bishop to e3 makes a ton of sense
here
uh and then from here you could see lots
of different options you could see
castle on the king side for black that
makes sense
uh you see that the knight here on a b6
they could take
i don't think they're really going to
take but you have to be aware of it
because you could just take here on a4
this is check and so they could play
bishop to e7 or d7
attacking the queen queen to c4 you
still want to keep your pieces very
active in the board
uh so queen two c four
attacks the square here on uh f7 they
could play
uh e5 at this point if they wanted to
but now you could take
if they take here uh you could play
knight to f3
normal development move attacking the
bishop they could take down here on
b2 rook b1 bishop comes back and then
you take here
on b7 so that's one option uh they could
also instead of trying to just push
forward on e5
castle on the king side of the board
but same thing white's going to play
knight to f3 now if they push it's even
worse because the knight is here on
f3 so i don't really think they're gonna
be taking
uh with their knights on uh a4
before uh they cast on the king side so
they definitely could cast on the king
side i think that makes the most sense
uh knight to f3 same thing as we've
talked about before
now if we start to look at it maybe they
do want to take this knight at some
point
so they could play queen to d7
preparing to go ahead and take here
since they're protecting it with their
queen
but now we can just play knight to c5 uh
both attacking the queen here on d7 and
also this pawn on
b7 which kind of holds this bishop here
on
c8 for a while they could bring their
queen back to e8 you could play rook to
c1 you always
want to bring your rooks to open or
semi-open files which this
c file is a semi-open file so that's
going to be a pretty good square for it
another alternative is maybe bishop to
g4 pinning down the knights here so
you have the the queen which they may
think that you would have to recapture
with your queen right here
uh but i would still just play knight to
c5 you always want to look at the
the material left behind that was und or
that was defended and is now
undefended the pawn here on a b7 as soon
as this bishop leaves
this pawn is now undefended now they can
always bring their bishop back
that's definitely an option but it
doesn't make a ton of sense because
they're losing tempo
and so now you have a square that you
can start to attack at some point now if
they do take i recommend recapturing
with your pawn here
on f3 you can still castle on the king
side at some point
but this still solidifies the center of
the board
and you do want to keep your queen and
your bishop here on e3
protecting the square on d4
the next variation we're going to look
at is knight to c6
normal development move from black
attacking the pawn here on d4
white's going to continue same plan e4
attacking the knight the knights either
going to come to b6
or it's going to come to f6 we'll look
at both options
if they play f6 you have two options if
you don't like having fun
then you could always play e5 pretty
safe move they played knight to
d5 you played knight two f3
and then you question why you are
playing moves that aren't fun instead
you're gonna play the fun move and that
is d5 and the reason this is fun
is it's a trap because if your opponent
looks at this long enough it almost
feels like
okay you're attacking my knight here on
c6
but if you take what happens if they
take here on e4
because if we take their knights then
all of a sudden they can play the move
queen takes on d1
king recaptures and the knight takes on
f2
attacking the king forking the rook here
on h1
king 2 e1 and then knight takes on h1
pawn takes b7 bishop recaptures and this
is a
terrible spot for white you can clearly
see that but instead
uh white doesn't have to take this
knight here on c6 and instead
white has the nice move queen to d3
attacking the knight now how does this
knight
really stay in the game here and you can
also see that
if something happens maybe knight 2 f6
what we're really threatening is the
pawn takes now if the queen takes here
then the bishop can take here on d3 so
we don't want the king recapturing here
but if we start to look at okay queen
two d3 now what does black do oh
they have a few options here they could
take here on f2 as we talked about
because the only option is take with the
the king right here
now knight to e5 queen check
queen to b3 here attacking the pawn here
on b7 also still defending
this central pawn in the center of the
board
they could say okay that's not going to
work out we're going to go down material
and they can easily defend against that
so they could try to protect it maybe
bishop to f5
this holds it down right here but then
you could just take
and then if they take the queen that's
fine because after the pawn recaptures
on c6
then g4 this bishop is going to have to
move and then
the knight's going to fall here so
that's not going to work out very well
they could also try to hold it down with
the pawn
but it's going to have the same fate
because pawn takes on
c6 and after the queen takes bishop
takes on
d3 and then after the pawn takes then
you could see
knight two f3 bishop e6
bishop to f4 and white's gonna have a
very good game here has all their minor
pieces all the minor pieces
uh black only has three in the game so
i do like if we coming back to this
position i like really pushing up with
d5 attacking the knight and the knight
doesn't have a lot of great squares it
can always just come back to b8
but that's pretty awkward and if they
look at this
it's really tempting for them to just
take this pawn here on
e4
now coming back two moves they don't
have to come to f6 they could definitely
play
knight to b6 and if this is the case
we're just going to push forward with
d5 they can always play knight to e5
and then we're going to bring our knight
back here to c3 not the most glamorous
but
this does protect the center of the
board right here
and one of the things that uh you know
isn't great for whites is
when you're playing against the grunfeld
defense you play this knight to c3 but
the knight on c3
usually ends up falling and then you
just exchange it with your pawn on c3
well now
you can control both of these light
squares in the center of the board
and your knight on c3 is not going to be
exchanged off by one of the knights you
can get your bishops involved very
easily
you can play knight to f3 at some point
and you still have center control
the next version we're going to look at
is e5 countering in
the center of the board we're always
going to be taking here on e5 and they
have a few options
the first option would be knight to c6
simple development move attacking this
pawn right here
we're going to play knight to f3 we're
up in material this knight
is a normal move that we would be making
but it also protects the pawn here on e5
so that's definitely going to be a good
thing
they could attack this uh knight right
away maybe bishop to
a g4 and then there's a critical move
here and that is
a3 because we're really stopping the
thread of bishop down to
b4 check things get pretty wonky and
they can even do that before
the bishop comes down to g4 they could
do it at this move just bishop down to
b4 check we play bishop to c2
and even they don't have to do it at
this point they can do it before the
knight comes to
c6 so this is something just to be aware
of if you take here on
e5 they could play bishop to b4
you play bishop to d2 and they could
play knight to
e3 now i think the best move from black
if you analyze it is queen
to e7 this is attacking the pawn right
here
still supports this bishop here on b4
but
you could be playing some crazy people
and they could play knight to e3
in this case you can't take with your
bishop here because it's being pinned
down by this bishop right here so you
take with your pawn
they take with their bishop you can't
take with your king it's being protected
by the queen up here so
you take with your queen they come down
here queen to h4
check and then after g3 they take with
their queen over here on a four and then
white plays knight to
f3 it's not the easiest position white
is up in material the good thing is this
pawn on
e5 is on a dark square this bishop is on
a light square
so this bishop's never going to be able
to attack this now they could play
c6 that does attack right away but it's
being defended by the knight
pretty nicely and so it's going to be
difficult for black to really get this
material yes white does have
three pawns all on the e-file but white
is up in material
doesn't have any sort of minor piece
disadvantage on the board so white
definitely has a good game here and i
think this is completely fine but just
be aware of that
if you ever run into that position now
if they don't bring
the bishop down to b4 they could also
play bishop to
g7 we already looked at knight to c6
attacking
this pawn but g7 is a common move in the
grunfeld defense so you could definitely
see that as well
just start attacking pieces pawn to e4
attacking the knight right here
maybe knight comes back to b6 queen
takes on
d8 after the exchange queen two g5 now
you're starting to get material involved
into the game king to e8
knight back here to c3 uh defending
the central pawn bishop takes here on e5
now knight to f3 just getting more
material involved into the game yes they
can take
this knight if they want to but if they
do
they will be able to attack an isolated
pawn here uh but also white now has the
bishop pair
and so uh both sides equal in material
but
in an open board state like this i'm
definitely taking the bishop pair
um from white i think that's going to be
the the better option
going into the middle and end game
the last variation we're going to look
at is if they play pawn to b5 they may
not know what you're doing if you play
knight to a4
kind of looks like you're a crazy person
so they could just start throwing all
their material trying to
see how they can get you in a tough
position pawn to b5 but knight to c5
is a great little outpost they have no
pawns that can ever
force this knight to move and so how do
they really respond here well they could
play bishop 2 g7
the main themes that they are used to
playing
you're going to continue with this same
thing that you're used to playing and
that is e4
attacking this knight right here maybe
knight comes back here to
b6 and then i recommend knight to f3
yes you could play bishop to b5
check the problem is they can play c6
pretty easily
the bishop comes back and then you're in
a tough spot because queen takes on
d4 if you take it
yes their bishop recaptures but you can
see you've lost
control of the center of the board
they're attacking your knight here on c5
this is not a position that's going to
go favorably for white so instead
while it does look tempting and you can
take this at some point
i recommend first playing knight to f3
you really want to control
this pawn here on a d4 now they have a
couple options one
they could let you take this pawn here
on b5 which isn't great or they could
start to play something like a6 but this
is
not really when you start to think about
all
the the moves that they want to be
playing in the groomfell defense this is
not how they want to do it
protecting their pawn here on b5 with a6
this is just letting you control the
center of the board they really want to
be building around
this bishop on g7 and getting their
other pieces to attack this year on the
board if they're playing a6
that feels like a very big win
for you now we come back maybe they
don't play bishop to g7
maybe they play something else who knows
really what they could play in this
position knight two
d7 maybe you're still pushing forward
with
e4 here maybe if they take
you take with your own pawn here on uh
c5 maybe they play b4 things get
crazy now bishop takes on
b5 check maybe they play c6
you could play a3 just say hey if you
want to take my queen that's fine we
could have an exchange on the board
white's gonna be up in material yes they
have double pawns on the b
file uh but supporting this pass pawn
right here
on the c file you have a semi-open file
that your rook can get involved into the
game
it's just very difficult to see how
they're going to
respond so yeah if you see that pawn to
b5 definitely wouldn't be too worried
after knight to c5 you're going to be in
a
pretty good spot hopefully you enjoyed
this video on a creative way to
attack the greenfield defense it's a
very common defense from black so you
get a lot of opportunity to play it
but this is one that i fancy myself so
let me know what your favorite defense
against the grunfeld defense is or if
you've tried this out and you've had
success let me know
if there's other variations that you
want to see feel free to let me know in
the comments you can always reach me
on my website thejustwebsite.com you can
always reach out to me via email
the chess website at gmail.com but thank
you so much for watching the video if
you haven't already
hit the like button make sure you are
subscribed so you can make sure
that you are notified anytime i make
more videos but thanks so much and i'll
see you in the next video